even his male moviegoers are slow to let
go of Angelina Jolie's amazing
technicolor dream breasts women are
asking themselves what about my boobies
are they fetching objects of desire or
ticking time bombs along with that
spectacular jawline and an immune system
strong enough to survive a 4-year
marriage to Billy Bob Thornton Angelina
also inherited the deadly bracket one
gene which jacked up her odds of breast
cancer so high that she took pre-emptive
action and had a prophylactic double
mastectomy if only she'd shown the same
foresight before filming the tourist
angelina learn about her risks because
of the sort of medical innovation in
which the US has long been the clear
leader she benefited from a genetic test
that is at the center of a Supreme Court
case challenging test maker myriad
technologies right to enforce genetic
patents the ACLU and others have sued
the biotech giant saying you can't
patent products nature or even seemingly
unnatural products like Angelina's
perfect lips however the case plays out
here's something to think about over the
past few decades America has led the
world in the number of new drugs being
developed and I'm not just talking about
purple kush we've also led the way in
developing a host of new technologies
like MRI CT scans and genomic sequencing
we haven't been number one because
American researchers are smarter however
messed up America's health care system
might be it's still more driven by free
markets than virtually any other place
that's where innovation and change and
the next life-saving breakthroughs come
with the right incentives even Jenny
McCarthy could come up with a
life-saving vaccines Angelina's test
costs north of three thousand dollars
well out of the price range of most
women in America but like VCR cell
phones and Lindsay Lohan's dignity
things that start out expensive and rare
quickly become cheap and ubiquitous it's
not clear how the Supreme Court will
rule in the myriad technologies case but
this is more certain than the fact
there's not going to be a sequel to salt
as obamacare kicks in groundbreaking
genetic tests and preventive surgeries
will remain elusive perks of the
privileged as innovation and patient
choice are always the first things to go
when bureaucracy and the state takeover
health care for reason TV I'm Kennedy
you